okay I'm back I am horizontal sorry
about that I will never never ever do
vertical video again I truly do
apologize I didn't mean to mess with
people by being vertical I know vertical
video is clearly clearly did not work
well for our purposes here okay so I'm
back and we have never been more
vertical than we are now so anyway yeah
listen we're gonna do on on our next
show I am going to do a breakdown of
everything that Donald Trump claimed as
an accomplishment during this bizarre
press conference we're gonna break down
exactly which one of those count as
accomplishments and and which ones
really don't okay so that's going to be
on our next program the reason I
actually wanted to talk about the Donald
Trump press conference right now is
tomorrow we have this story coming up on
the show which is going to make it so
that between phone calls and all the
other stuff that we have going on on the
Friday show I'm just not gonna have time
to talk about the press conference
tomorrow because we have a story
tomorrow that we've been working on
about fake actual fake news and
disinformation now by fake news I don't
mean news I disagree with politically
okay I do not mean that what I mean by
fake news is these sort of conspiracy
actual made-up news websites and during
the run-up to the 2016 election we saw
that undeniably
the fake news was sort of Pro Trump
anti-hillary fake news in other words it
was bringing it was sort of the
opposition fake news with the idea that
it was Democrats and Obama in power at
the time okay under Trump now fake news
is actually leaning left now I know
you're going to say well hold on a
second Breitbart Infowars etc etc
absolutely no doubt about it but a study
that was done by Stanford looked at the
totality of fake news sites and it is
starting to lean left and the point I'm
going to make tomorrow I'm going to give
you some examples of that okay but the
point I'm going to make tomorrow is
under Obama
the anti-obama fake news was not
necessary in a literal sense but it made
more sense to me because Obama basically
had no scandals for eight years I don't
think it's necessary for the left to do
fake news under Trump because there's so
much actual crazy stuff going on under
Trump and that only goes to confirm in
my mind that the impetus of fake news is
not necessarily to influence opinion
it's it's really up the profit motive
because fake news is quite profitable
and advertisers are spending money on
these websites that being said it's it
there's no doubt that some fake news is
ideologically driven but at the same
time there's a number of really good
in-depth stories that have been done
with different fake news purveyors and
most of them say I don't
some of them say I don't care about
politics and then others say I care
about politics but that's not how I
choose stories I just choose stories
that are gonna bring in ad dollars and
make money etc etc so that's something
really really interesting that we're
gonna be covering on tomorrow's show
extensively in the first segment and and
as a result I probably am NOT going to
have time to deal with the trunk press
conference tomorrow which deserves time
right I mean there's no doubt that that
that's something that that we should be
paying attention to big thank you to
Megan Fox nah new david pakman show
member who has signed up at david
pakman.com literally during this live
stream using the coupon code
I voted 17 which will give you a 40%
discount most of you probably know our
program is viewer and a funded listener
funded and every single time that we get
a new sign up during this live stream I
will give a live shout-out and thank you
and this one goes to Megan Fox nor if
the if you want a discount coupon code I
voted 17 okay okay I've talked about the
Trump press conference a little bit I've
talked about disinformation fake news
leaning left under Trump here's
something else I wanted to mention so
we've been doing the survey at day
pakman.com slash survey which I hope you
will take and and sort of give us some
feedback about what what we're doing
that you like what we're doing that you
don't like for the trolls there's even
like a open comment field where you
could call me a [ __ ] or you know make
fun of me for being Jewish or all that
sort of normal stuff that gets your
opinion completely weed it out when we
actually figure out what to do next one
of the really interesting things that
has come up in the survey is
overwhelmingly the audience seems to
want longer interviews and this applies
not only to the podcast audience I would
expect that if someone is listening to
an hour podcast that's the type of
audience member who would be interested
in a longer interview but even among
youtube viewers people who primarily
consume the david pakman show on YouTube
the number one sort of desire is for
longer interviews and I figured out a
way not that it was that complex to do
longer interviews but not to make them
take up more of each show which is we've
already booked and we actually did this
week with Peter Boghossian a two-part
interview and the two-part interview
will allow me to in total have like a
thirty minute twenty five to thirty
minute conversation with guests that are
interesting but it will still only be
one segment of the one hour Daily Show
so if you don't watch the interviews and
you just watch the five minute clips on
YouTube none of this matters and it
won't make any difference for you but if
you like the interviews we will be we
won't separate them on YouTube so on the
broadcast show we might have like a
Monday Tuesday two-parter but it'll be
all together on YouTube and I think that
this is I mean usually everything that
we do has a downside but I don't think
that this has any downside because if
you want longer interviews you'll get
them but if you don't care about the
interviews we're still going to be able
to do seven to eight stories per show so
I I think that that is going to be a
good thing we've got a couple of
interviews
lined up already that are going to be
like this again we had Peter Boghossian
today the the interview that was on
today's broadcast show which was with
Andrew Torres he's the host of the
opening arguments legal podcast which is
awesome and and you should check it out
we maybe we could have gone to parts
with him but the problem was being
Thursday on Friday we do a classic
interview from the archives with a new
commentary so we would have pushed part
two over the weekend anyway it didn't
seem to make sense so a few comments
coming through here number one when I
say we do we have a team yes we do we
have david pakman show producer Pat
Forde we have david pakman show segment
producer noah ferguson who has been
responsible for and when i say
responsible for it almost sounds like
i'm blaming someone but what it's really
praised he has been involved in some of
the great viral long-form pieces that
we've done starting in january of last
year with the reza aslan cannot be
trusted video undocumented immigration
video alright etc etc so that we have
noah Ferguson who is doing a lot of
great research we also have intern
melody who works in our studio a couple
days a week and then there's a whole
bunch of other people sort of on the
team we've got two reddit moderators
that are helping to control the trolling
that's going on there we have a number
of different contributors that have
contributed graphics over the last
couple of weeks we've got Jeremy
paczynski who is involved in the new
graphics that have been rolling out on
the show and more will roll out over the
next week or so we've also got Tyler
Twombly who got in touch and said hey I
want to contribute something what if I
do a new podcast icon which has already
been rolled out and a whole bunch of
different stuff that's been going on so
the team is growing and if things go
well it's going to continue to continue
to grow someone mentioned in the
comments that Genki huger from the young
turks agrees with me on trump's literacy
issues if offline if he actually if they
played our video or commented on our
story i would want to add that to our
mentions on other meet
list so email me if that's the case if
if junk.just also mentioned independent
of our story that he thinks Trump has
literacy issues then then I guess that's
not something that I would put on the
channel okay let me dig into a little
more specifically about the Donald Trump
press conference and before we do that
thank you - wow this is a long list
thank you to Amanda Bennett who has just
become a david pakman show member thomas
sevilla Sevilla great city in Spain who
has just become a david pakman show
member Erik Anderson who has just signed
up with the coupon code I voted 17
Laurie Kelly who has signed up with the
coupon code I voted 17 Arturo Alviar as
well as Robin loose so a lot of new
David Pakman show members live shout
outs and thank-yous there's Thomas in
the comments you can use the coupon code
I voted 17 okay so let me pull up oh no
our reddit already has an uploaded video
apparently of me going from vertical to
horizontal and it was a disaster okay
our great reddit moderator gloom skull
put together a bunch of the discussion
points from Donald Trump's press
conference let's go through it and I
think you're gonna very quickly see that
this was one of the most unusual bizarre
but also substance lists press
conference that that press conferences
that we've seen the lying media right so
attack the media I think at this point
it's a disastrous idea for Trump to be
attacking not only the media but also
our intelligence agencies media is going
to increasingly fact-check Trump and by
fact-check I'm not suggesting anything
untoward just fact-checking which is a
disaster for Trump any fact-checking of
what Trump does is bad for Trump and our
intelligence agencies have made it
abundantly clear that they have a ton of
crap on Trump the Russia stuff today
yesterday today in the last 24 hours the
FBI released a bunch of the documents
from that lawsuit against Donald Trump
in the 70s for race-based discrimination
and the
the documents are absolutely and utterly
insane so if I were Trump it just seems
like bad strategy to go after the media
as well as intelligence agencies that's
what he did Donald Trump talked about
having inherited massive challenges from
President Obama and that that's why if
you're seeing anything not go well
it's not his fault does anybody else
remember how when Democrats accurately
said that about Donald Trump about
Barack Obama inheriting a disastrous
economy and military situation overseas
from george w bush the republicans said
hey obama's the president it's all
Obama's fault
and now all of a sudden when Trump wants
to blame Obama incorrectly by the way a
very strong economy doesn't mean there
isn't poverty it doesn't mean there
aren't people who would rather be making
more money underemployed wage issues but
a very strong economy and now all of a
sudden that same explanation hey I
inherited challenges from Obama now all
of a sudden people are buying into that
doesn't make any sense to me bragging
bragging about his great diplomatic
deals flag and this is this is again
from glooms skulls great post on our
reddit discussion forum and it's every
single thing that you're that we saw
trump talked about was either
hypocritical or just made no sense
whatsoever the accomplishments and I'm
gonna break this down more next week the
accomplishments Trump cited are not
really accomplishments right I mean he
touted withdrawing from TPP TPP was dead
TPP was dead when President Trump took
over it was abundantly clear November
15th we heard from Chuck Schumer and
Mitch McConnell the u.s. is not signing
on to TPP Trump's calling it an
accomplishment of his administration
getting us out of TPP deregulation for
private business and corporation again
executive order which hasn't actually
done anything yet it's directing
Congress to do something things haven't
really been done the few things that
have been done quietly by Congress are
absolute disaster
okay and we're gonna dig it more into
that the hiring freeze on government
employees I've already talked about this
when you arbitrarily so if your
government if you're a business if
you're any organization you should hire
people when you need people to do work
right if there's demand for labor you
should hire people and if there's stuff
to be done by the government because the
government does things then you should
you should hire people when you do a
federal a hiring freeze on government
employees if there's work to be done you
end up hiring contractors and
contractors end up costing way more in
two ways number one on an hourly wage
basis you typically pay more for a
contractor than a w-2 employee that's
just a general rule of how hiring works
but more importantly when you bring in
outsiders as contractors you then are
wasting time on inefficiencies because
outsiders are going to need to learn the
system they're going to need to learn
all sorts of stuff that an employee
would know and and the working
relationship is a disaster Jimmy Carter
tried this I believe that there was a
hiring freeze under Reagan as well it
was a Republican and a Democrat who both
tried it and it really just just didn't
work okay so so that's again an
accomplishment Trump cited during this
bizarre gong show press conference that
made no sense I'll just pick a couple
others here okay here's a perfect
example of what I talked about yesterday
on the show and my segment called dokdo
trumpets realized trump has accomplished
nothing Donald Trump cited as an
accomplishment that he directed the
creation of a task force for reducing
violent crime in America okay I dealt
with this yesterday who's against
reducing Virant violent crime in America
nobody other than the people wanting to
commit violent crime Donald Trump
signing an executive order directing the
creation of a task force again it
doesn't actually do anything and this
also applies and this is the last one
I'll deal with today Donald Trump
directing moving forward with the Dakota
access pipeline and Keystone XL it's
terrible that the president is
suggesting that we go for
with these antiquated fossil fuel
technologies that other countries laugh
at us when we say hey Oh China's the
leader now India's the leader on
alternative energy we're gonna bring
back Kol jobs the world is laughing okay
but again it's not an it's not actually
something tangible to say we want to go
forward with that it's an executive
order that doesn't really do too much
okay let me address a few things that
people are mentioning one people
mentioning this weird caricature cartoon
of me right over here yeah this is very
old and I genuinely never thought that
it really looked much like me I guess
what's exaggerated in it is my chin my
chin doesn't really stick out in that
way my eyes being close together that's
something people have mentioned so maybe
maybe that's something but yeah I've
never thought it was that good but it's
on the wall and I've never never taken
it off the nose people are asking about
I don't know maybe maybe there's
something to the nose I'm not really uh
not really sure about that okay a couple
more big thank yous to people on the
stream who has have signed up for
memberships while I've been talking here
Catherine may using the coupon code 33
today Jennifer ESCO using the coupon
code
I voted seventeen and Cody Johnson
signing up at david pakman.com slash
membership again with the coupon code
I voted seven seventeen it gives you a
40% discount you decide if 40 percent
sounds like a good discount off of
membership and of course you get the
daily bonus show when you sign up for
that then hey you decide to use it or or
not to use it okay so listen those are
some of my general thoughts about the
Trump press conference the funniest line
may be the one cited at the end in this
great reddit post at david pakman.com
slash read it by gloom skull that he put
together quoting trump when Trump said
I'm not a bad person by the way I get
good ratings so certainly one of the
more unusual press conferences if this
is what we have to
forward to for nearly four years
it's gonna be the funniest thing we've
ever experienced it makes George W Bush
look like a sort of bright articulate
thoughtful individual which is insane I
never thought I think i praise george w
bush more in the 26 days that donald
trump has been the president then i did
during the entire eight years that
george w bush was president okay let me
deal with a couple other things
questions have been coming in about well
basically there's two things were
questions that can coming in we did this
indiegogo fundraiser that ended nearly a
month ago okay and there were a lot of
things we wanted to do we fell short of
the total goal but we still raised
enough money to do some of the things
that we wanted to do okay
so progressive engagement coordinator
david pakman show on amazon prime studio
redesign okay let me address those three
things let me start with david pakman
show on amazon prime amazon prime we've
been working with them very aggressively
to get the program on amazon prime
because it's it's a very large platform
it would be really great to be on there
the issue we're having and this is the
same issue some other shows i've been in
touch with have had is that Amazon Prime
has put in place arguably the most
aggressive restrictions on what the
program can look like so to give you a
couple of examples we used to have in
the lower right corner of our show a
little David Pakman show logo that was
kind of animated it would have like a
light flair and we submitted the program
to Amazon Prime and they came back and
said you're not allowed to have any
static graphics that pervade the entire
show which referenced our little David
Pakman show bug so we got rid of that
and we resubmitted the show and then
they came back and they said you must
have subtitles for every single show so
that it is accessible to the heart of
hearing which I actually think is a
great thing but we had to figure out how
to do that we went back and
I asked for audience recommendations we
found a service that would turn around
in within about an hour and a half a
full transcript of the show in subtitle
format resubmitted it to Amazon Prime
for approval they came back they said it
appears as though on screen you have
graphics that reference external
websites during the show of course we do
I mean we record we have a graphic about
membership when we have a guest on we
have a graphic for the guests website at
the end or beginning of segments we
might have a logo going to facebook.com
slash david pakman show or whatever so
basically we need to remove everything
from the show that makes it what I
consider a better produced show than we
had two years ago in order to get it
accepted on Amazon Prime and so because
we didn't raise all the money we wanted
to I'm thinking that that would be what
we drop from our plan I we're still
moving forward with the progressive
engagement coordinator we've been taking
applications for people who want to work
on that side out of our Boston studio
and that is still happening and in
addition to that the new studio design
is on its way now I'm going to be
totally honest with you about what's
going on during the fundraiser process
we had a studio designer come in we
talked about budget we talked about what
I want and we've been going back and
forth with some designs we just recently
sort of finalized what the design it's
going to be and it came back at twice
the cost that we had initially talked
about so right now we're basically in
the now that we figured out what we want
how can we get it back to the budget
that we were talking about but the
studio redesign is absolutely going to
happen it's going to significantly match
the new graphics and the color schemes
and all of that okay so that's the
latest as far as that's going on we have
a super chat that was sent by mister
steal yo counter-argument which says how
do you feel about how divided gamergate
became over Trump in the past year I
think it's the last bipartisan social
movement we'll have in a while I have no
idea what you're talking about
I have almost complete
the tuned out to what has been going on
with gamergate since our interviews on
the subject kind of ended so I didn't
know I don't know if you mean that
gamergate is divided in that some
gamergaters support Trump and some don't
or if you mean bipartisan in that
gamergaters and non gamergaters came
together around Trump I genuinely don't
know how to answer that because I have
no clue what on earth is going on with
that okay
so I'm sorry that I can't comment more
on that okay a couple more shout outs to
new subscribers that have signed up just
while I've been chatting here at david
pakman.com slash membership a holley
aguilar agiel or a galley or i hope i'm
pronouncing that somewhat right has
signed up with the coupon code
I voted 17 Matthew or meteo man I am
butchering some of these names
bissonnette's the last name I'm
confident with has signed up at david
pakman.com slash membership again with
the 40% coupon code I voted 17 and
robert baker robert baker also signing
up at david pakman show slash david
pakman.com slash membership i saw a
couple questions streamed through there
about who should play Stephen Miller on
Saturday Night Live so we were asked
this by voice mail I think it was on
yesterday's show I like the idea of the
guy who plays Sheldon Cooper from Big
Bang Theory playing Stephen Miller on
SNL and Parsons I Jim Parsons I think
his name is Jim Parsons I think that
that would be really funny but then
someone else came back to me and said
David the Paul Reubens
who does pee-wee Herman is the guy who
should be playing Stephen Miller which
is funny although Paul Rubens is a
little bit older now so I don't know I
mean I guess I'm sure he could be made
up in a way that
that it would work but then someone else
came and said David no no no you need a
woman you need a woman to play Stephen
Miller because when a woman played Sean
Spicer Melissa McCarthy Donald Trump
went completely off the deep end haywire
and that's what you just need to figure
out what woman you can get to play
Stephen Miller just to add what really
shouldn't be insult to injury but
apparently the Donald Trump is if a
woman plays a man yeah so okay a few
people discussing the David Pakman show
patreon we have basically shut down
patreon I don't actually know how to
delete the page but we transitioned we
only got I realized when we were doing
patreon it was cannibalizing our
membership and also confusing people
where people didn't know well what's the
difference between patreon and
membership and if I have one but not the
other do I get the same stuff for
different stuff etc so patreon is
basically shut down and we're just doing
the membership thing and all that all
the benefits are under under membership
and hate to respond to what clarf
one-two-three-four is saying patreon was
not cheaper was not cheaper than
membership it was $1.00 less per month
if you did the $5 a month thing but you
had way fewer perks
okay-y known a rider playing Stephen
Miller on Saturday Night Live I like
that
someone just mentioned that who was that
that mentioned that it was boy the chat
is going so quickly I can't even find it
well listen I apologize someone
suggested why known a writer I Stephen
Miller has this sort of like kind of
small oval head and I think that if wine
owned a writer were able to sort of pull
back all the hair or maybe wear like a
one of those bald caps and then a toupee
on top of it I think that that would
work pretty well to be to be Stephen
Miller there I like it okay predictions
about so yeah tonight my Logan appleís
is going to be on Bill Maher's show
Jamie yeah jeremy scahill
tweeted that he was bailing on the Bill
Maher appearance because Milo is going
to be on the Bill Maher show I have no
idea what to expect I hope as someone
who has interviewed Milo before years
ago before he became who he is now I
hope that Bill Maher is going to be
adversarial and confrontational but I
really don't know what to expect a
couple people emailed me saying they
think that Bill Maher is going to be in
some way supportive of the concept of
what Milo is doing while not agreeing
with his politics so I don't really know
what to expect okay a couple other new
members that I want to say a big thank
you to that just signed up while we've
been chatting here Scott Williams and
Terrell Turner as well as no boy
constantina / Paris Pere Parise some of
these names are not the easiest to say
thank you to the three of you for
signing up at david pakman.com slash
membership and you can indeed use the
coupon code
I voted 17 for a discount I saw another
idea just float by in the chat which is
what about getting a man to play
evanka or Melania even on Saturday Night
Live I think that that would be a really
great idea let me address something a
lot of people are talking about me
debating steven crowder who i believe i
only know about him a little bit I think
he's a Canadian guy who talks mostly now
I guess about US politics I don't know
if he's based in the US or not
I saw one video of his and he has a ton
of YouTube subscribers and he some
people saying that he would destroy this
[ __ ] referring to me during a debate or
whatever I would be perfectly fine
talking to him and having a conversation
you know the the idea that he would
destroy me in a debate I mean I think it
depends on well what
what's the conversation what's the topic
and what's the format of it that the
kanji to this idea of destroying people
in debates what it really comes down to
is sort of like what what are the facts
and the preparation and knowledge that
each person has it seems odd to me to
just say offhand that as a [ __ ] which
apparently I am that's one of the more
common words I think at this point on
the on the channel that I'd get
destroyed by steven crowder i'd be
thrilled to have him on and I I don't
know if that's something he's interested
in doing or or whatever okay so we can
we can absolutely look into that okay
what else did I have that I wanted to
mention we already talked about to catch
you up if you've just joined we ought we
started with vertical video it was a
disaster I disconnected we reconnected
with horizontal video and since then
we've talked about the Donald Trump Gong
Show press conference today we've talked
about a story we're doing on tomorrow's
show of misinformation disinformation
fake news leaning left under Donald
Trump we're gonna talk about that
tomorrow
I've talked about upcoming changes to
the David Pakman show I've talked about
the long interviews that we're going to
be doing new graphics etc etc and we've
done a lot of shout outs that people
have that have signed up for membership
also let me address that there's there's
a lot of drama going on with Dave Rubin
okay and so I think I've never hidden
the fact that I've been in touch with
Dave Rubin for a while will text or
email back and forth with not huge
frequency but every few weeks there's
for whatever reason we text back and
forth for a while and then we don't hear
from each other for a while he's been on
my show I've been on his show there's a
lot of people and there's a caller on
this week who called in basically saying
it was sort of like I don't know that
I'd use the word baiting but basically
trying to get me to issue some kind of
general critique of Dave Rubin and I
don't I don't shy away no
go towards criticizing or praising
anybody just because I know them
personally and I've said sort of what
what I would say to Dave Rubin if we
were to talk and maybe at some point
he'd be back on my show or I'd be on his
which is I don't subscribe to the
criticism of him that his interviewing
style is not to go point/counterpoint
okay that's an interviewing technique
sometimes I recently interviewed this
alt-right leader Richard Spencer white
nationalist dude and people criticized
me because I wasn't on every single
point that he made shouting him down or
belaboring it because I sort of realized
that we're gonna learn more from
figuring out where a number of his ideas
come from and what they're based on than
me just completely interrupting the
interview and we just spent thirty five
minutes arguing about the first thing he
says okay so the criticism of Ruben that
he doesn't go adversarial during an
interview I don't think is a legit
criticism where I would take issue with
a sort of editorial decision that he
made and again I have no problem saying
this to Dave and and hopefully at some
point we can talk about it on my show or
his show he did do an interview and I
don't even remember the person's name I
think it was this young dude whose name
escapes me who has been sort of like the
champion of the Millennial pro
fossil-fuel movement it's this dude who
goes around and he's very very I'm sure
someone knows this guy's name he's very
very smooth at presenting information
about climate change to make it seem as
though we really just don't know and we
can't trust the 99% of scientists
whatever and there was what what I
thought was it was a little bit
concerning to me Alex Epstein yes Joel
Ortega Alec and Clark also saying Alex
Epstein that's exactly who it is I think
that it's concerning and Kyle kolinsky
had a good talk a good video about this
lately and again would date with Kyle
again someone that I text with
with some frequency things I agree with
him on things I disagree reasonable
people can disagree and we can talk
about stuff Kyle had a really good video
that I don't think at anything to do
with Dave Rubin but he said we shouldn't
confuse neutrality with objectivity and
I think that there are times where it
can be dangerous to be neutral when
neutrality is in no way objective and
the sort of caricature of this is if we
were to have after the basta the New
England Patriots destroy the Atlanta
Falcons right I mean the Atlanta Falcons
have this game where they fall apart in
really in a historic way in terms of the
lead that that they lost in that Super
Bowl 51 if afterwards we have five
panelists four of whom want to talk
about what an amazing victory it was
that the New England Patriots were able
to achieve and then one guest who says
yet the Falcons won the game right we
would say well that's that might have
the appearance of neutrality because
you're giving voice to differing
opinions but there's nothing objective
of that because objectivity tells us
that the New England Patriots won the
game it's a caricature sort of like this
one right here of me that's behind me
but it's an example of why I think that
that that can be problematic and
hopefully I can have Dave on or he'll
have me on his show and we can sort of
dig into this issue a little more so if
someone's looking for a blanket
criticism of Dave because he doesn't
yell at the people that he interviews
that you're not going to see that from
me but I'm glad to sort of explore
specific positions that that he takes
and and we can look at that okay big
thank you to Carol Newsome who has just
created a David Pakman show membership
at david pakman.com slash membership as
well as Benjamin Ramos who has signed up
with the coupon code
I voted 17 at david pakman.com slash
membership people asking what do you get
with a membership so number one if
you're used to watching three to
five-minute clips on youtube our members
every single day way earlier by the way
then the youtube clips come out get a
one hour - the commercial
so it ends up being about 51 minutes a
51 minute single video with the entire
show so we release our clips on a 90
minute interval starting at 4:30 p.m.
for that day's show members get the full
hour without commercials as a video it's
usually up by around 4 o'clock or
something like that and in addition to
that we do an entire additional show
just for our paid subscribers it's
called the bonus show we do different
types of stories it's less its political
but we also do tech stories we also do
previews or behind the scenes stuff
that's going on with the show
we'll talk about upcoming interviews and
all of this sort of thing to quote
Arnold Schwarzenegger and we every once
in a while we also do other stuff like a
members-only video conference and that
type of thing alright so thanks to
everybody who has signed up during the
stream I voted 17 gives you a 40%
discount for all of that stuff making it
only three dollars and 60 cents a month
to be a member okay last thing I want to
mention here before I move on from the
chat I've gotten I've seen it in the
chat and a few people have asked me my
thoughts on Brianna woo-hooo if you
don't know who she is don't don't worry
about it but she was the first gamergate
related interview I think that I did a
year and a half ago or something like
that she's I guess prog running as a
primary challenger to Stephen Lynch
who's a congressman here in
Massachusetts I believe it's Stephen
Lynch I hope I hope I have that right
and people have asked me if I've taken a
position on that
I haven't I know very little about it I
don't know what her platform is I don't
know what her purported qualifications
are or anything like that
so I can't comment but if it appears as
though she has a shot we don't really do
too much commenting on primary House
races especially Democratic primaries in
blue states like Massachusetts but if at
some point it seems as though I should
be commenting on that believe me that I
will joël boos Lee thank you for
subscribing with the coupon code
I voted 17 and there he is saying
done in the chat really appreciate it I
will do another livestream soon and
we've got a great show coming up for you
tomorrow